this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
yeah we're good chin what's up fam I
practice you what's up do you feel
different I do dude you're acting
different I feel I feel good do you
think you're gonna leave the show now
that you're in a Netflix stock
well
um I haven't seen this now I haven't
seen the document but I think it's gonna
just so everyone's aware chin Georgie
you realize callum's in the Johnny Depp
Amber Heard documentary on Netflix what
fans blew me up yesterday about it you
don't you don't know this either too I
had no idea that's insane I didn't
either and I never knew they were gonna
find out today I guess I did Patrick
David's podcast and they used clips of
me talking about I haven't seen it yet
dude I look great well you're against a
white backdrop yeah here's a nightmare
on that Jesus but um yeah whenever they
have a camera here you came in acting a
little different today and I was like uh
little cocky oh I knew it I knew it a
little cocky you know I came in and I
was like Hey I what the [__] is with uh
all this mess over here somebody cleaned
that up and I went like that with my
dude we had Paparazzi outside yeah like
tell us what it's like to meet Johnny
Depp you're like no no no no no no
didn't meet him I I did I did I was
standing next to Jimmy Burke when Jimmy
Burke hugged him uh at my uh Teddy
Demi's you got a whiff of him yeah Jimmy
Burke like looked at him and because I
was really good friends with Teddy I
loved what you said thank you so much
and he gave him a hug and uh and then he
just looked at me and he goes you know I
did that for you right I was like that
that's great you hugged him does he
smell like that was wearing a top hat
and he looked awesome does he smell like
a magic shop he he smells like magic
yeah I I just was like Dior I'm one of
those guys who's not cool around super
famous people this was this was this was
this was literally 20 years ago when he
was at the height of his Fame and beauty
and I'm just looking at Johnny Depp and
he's got a top hat so talented he's got
a top hat on and like he's dressed like
you know how he was when he was the Mad
Hatter yeah he looks like that and there
was a guy who was a friend of his who
was dressed in a similar way who had a
uh a walking stick with a cue ball on it
oh wow so he had that guy with those
guys into the dark arts dark arts yeah
and I'm looking at Johnny Depp and just
going you all never be this cool I'll
never be this talented and I I just was
looking at his face but I didn't
you should do what hot girls do you know
when the hot girls or they're trying to
get the hot guy they're mean to him yeah
you should just go out there and go you
know voodoo
he'll go excuse me you know Voodoo like
I don't know what you're talking about
will you dress like it right you look
ridiculous that's a very that might have
got his attention that's a legit
question dude that that question is the
most legit question Johnny do you know
do you know Voodoo you in the dark arts
or you just uh maybe maybe you a white
witch you know what I mean yeah white
witch you're a warlock you're a white
you yeah yeah yeah you a good warlock
you are you a druid see that would have
stuck out that would have stuck out I
think so I think so
uh what's the what is the uh formula to
immortality which you obviously have
orange you just came in and just caused
the whole scene like this guy drinks
kids blood right yeah but that was
before all that all those rooms I know
that's one been cool uh I'll tell you
this
there is this weird other subset
subculture which is the friends of big
celebrities
like Leo DiCaprio's friends Johnny
Depp's friends there's a there's a
there's that pod of people that are
always around him you know how in the
ocean there's a big fish there's like a
shark there's the little fish that the
feed off of the pilot fish yeah the
Marlin fish I don't want to be mean to
the people that are friends with them
because I don't know but another pilot
fan there is there's nothing wrong with
that meanwhile people are like what are
you guys with Rogan you know but but
there is a thing but we're not but
there's we don't make money off right
now those guys make money off Johnny and
they also do things for him yeah I mean
you're my pilot fish right
oh great white you little fish
underneath old fish you've been with me
a while bro
you pilot fish hey you know I gotta get
my beak wet right
you know how you get my beak wet right
hey Brian hey how much hey Brandon how
much do Netflix pay excuse me I'm on I'm
on a Netflix documentary you might want
to rephrase what you're saying because
it's different now it's different things
it's different now yeah I ain't no pilot
fish this pilot fish gotta spread Wings
yeah I'm about to go to another [__]
but to swim yeah about to swim on his
own you're about to find another big old
gray whale the copy that's right yeah
but I gotta get on the old another big
gray whale yeah okay probably a more
famous gray whale gotta do that no I
want to be on my own what do you mean
you pie the fish I want to navigate the
ocean on my own no you're not ready
you're like no no no just me Mom the dad
what yeah I'm the dad well I call you
Daddy yeah yeah hey hey Brennan take it
back hey take it back explain to me and
the listeners
how much Netflix pay for be featured on
Johnny Depp I'm glad you asked that
question now it's important to
understand I guess yeah
a million dollars six million it was six
million it was a little less than six
million maybe a lot less than six
million
um I didn't know that the I didn't even
know I didn't know they I never spoke to
anybody about it I wonder if they spoke
to Patrick David Beck because it's a
clip from his show Patrick because I
assume I just call him Pat he's close
yeah I don't know so I would assume
because it's his show they signed off on
Patrick signed off on it probably which
I'm totally happy with I'm you know well
you know how they're sitting around the
table imagine I was like excuse me I
assume Netflix sitting around and like
you know we have the we have Patrick on
here we got this like don't we need to
get a signature from Calumet he's fine
is that what they did do it he's good
that's how that went down is this it
right here
is that how you're looking at my where
I'm at now in my career well all this
time think about it he's fine it didn't
where'd you worked so hard in acting
that's the biggest thing you've done
that frustrating it's frustrating for me
dude
where this piece
is going okay this is massive dude yeah
Brian comes and goes I don't want to
talk about it
excuse me
I haven't seen it I haven't either all
right let's give it a play let's be
honest
can you please tell the jury while
you're here today Mr accused me of abuse
my ex-husband is suing me I'm a Fame
you're gonna see who the real Johnny
Depp is that was the one who wanted the
cameras in the courtroom she didn't I
didn't argument to PR campaign
good right six mil is that it for me
that's it that's it that's it then wow
yeah that's it that's why I made the
money hey Johnny Depp Conor McGregor
yeah it's a good year it's a good year
what do you mean Conor McGregor you're
in the Conor McGregor doc oh that's
right
man it's different now guys dude we're
just different I forgot I was in that
day we're just different I need some
magic mind [__] off need to get my head
right because you do you think Matt you
know what happens when I drink this and
I'm all [__] aside I get a flow
State uh it my my brain gets super clear
and I get aggressive and um this might
be an episode where I come at you
because of the Magic Man
just because I want this is my third one
today yeah yeah I know you gotta don't
overdo it the guys like you like Kyle
all these guys like these they go oh I
need another one right away it's like
hey hey calm the phone right away
oh it's good I told you I got my one
coffee I do a few of these and I'm the
brain is working
I love these I love the way they taste
it's true yeah
I wish it was even more green like I
want like I'm licking along James Bashar
who created it um like this we drank it
and somebody goes I want another one he
goes no take it easy man just one at a
time nah I don't get to all that if
you're big I suppose dude things are
just different now for us they're
different you're in the Johnny Depp and
now that I have nootropics running
through my [__] brain
dude now imagine if you took a magic
mine on the Johnny Depp
documentary
I would have been I would have been dude
my voice would have been even clearer
man
yeah I I now uh recognize my voice
anywhere I have a very unique voice oh
well I'd hope you'd recognize your voice
well but I have I I realize I think my
voice I've been told many times is
unique
but have asked me how many uh voiceovers
I've booked zero
not good at them
voiceovers I don't know why like Buffalo
Wild Wings can't do it Buffalo Wild
Wings I just I I think it's because I
can't get behind something I don't
believe in so if you want to [__] do
an ad it's true it's true I I you're
gonna hear the lie in my voice you're
like hey there's a lot of things you
could do though I don't know about this
it's not like they're asking you to push
you know
no also hey it's not like they're
sending a ton of deals you're waiting to
turn them down but I did when I was
younger well you know like Pepsi you
know drink Pepsi I love that I was like
[__] I can't like I would be like drink
Pepsi oh I'm lying I would yeah I love
Pepsi I can't do it
if I believe in it I'll I'll I'm
probably good or maybe I just
voiceovers are a very specific technique
yeah some people are so good at it oh my
God you wouldn't ask me for them I'm
like you guys don't want this voice
there's so many better people out there
well because when you start paying I
actually read for the Buffalo Wild Wings
like me I was I made the top five cut
Buffalo Wild Wings it's game time it's
not bad Buffalo Wild Wings it's game
time yeah that's what it was yeah try it
again that was good no something like
that I didn't do in that boy I can't do
that weird Buffalo Wild chaos 107.5
yeah that's the thing about radio hey
everybody this is the crack Brian Callan
here and it's eight o'clock in the
morning I hope you guys are having an
amazing time there in traffic and I'll
tell you what speaking of traffic
Chrysler is running an amazing sale I
was just down there and my buddy down
there Chet will give you the kind of
discount you're looking for right
have you seen that Sebring that thing is
fantastic I'll tell you what I thought
it was a BMW and I'm not kidding around
and you know you know I'm not lying
about that how you doing this morning
Brandon yeah radio's tough too because
they're like it's Monday Monday it's
that Monday for whatever resist Mondays
hit me extra hard who can relate to
let's take our first caller Catherine
calling in driving kids to school how
you doing Catherine is Monday kicking
your ass yeah it is it's totally kicking
my ass but you guys always get me
through it so I wanted to just thank you
and tell you uh go birds as usual the
405 is backed up and jam-packed that's
right weird and I'll tell you something
else out there you listeners this may
sound inappropriate but I got a boner
that could blunt a cat's claw you know
what I mean I'll tell you why because
Brennan's wearing a little biker cap and
it makes his head look extra small and
let's be honest the top of his head is
extra small there's not much of a brain
you know what I mean he's got a big body
with a small head and a tiny dick you
know what I'm saying all right guys
let's hear it for my boner right now
which could cut a diamond I don't know
why but I am hard as it gets and
speaking of hard I'll take it from here
pilot fish how about you suck me off at
the commercial break
don't call me a pilot fish you stupid
son of a [__] you're a fat [__]
whale and you're gonna die soon
as well you pilot fish and I'm getting
sick of it that's true but I'll Be
Dancing On Your Grave you piece of
[__] [__] you're a big old mud pie
you overgrown whale and I hope you sink
let's cut the break Buffalo Wild Wings
NFL season is here get the new Hot Wing
from Buffalo Buffalo Wild Wings Buffalo
Wild we're getting wide that's right you
know what guys your [__] will be gone
because we had some hot wings for you
that's why you remember when Buffalo
Wild Wings there's a chicken wing
shortage and like Buffalo Wild Wings now
has chicken sandwiches no longer just
specialized in Buffalo Wings we have
Burgers that's right get the extra hot
chicken sandwich I'll tell you what I
ate one of those tore my guts up it was
delicious but about an hour later I bent
over and I shat against the wall and I
was exactly 10 feet away from the wall
if you want explosive diarrhea we are
your people Buffalo Wild Wings Buffalo
Wild great
uh I'm gonna cheek slap your face with
my boner how's that sound Brennan dude
how about you in the Johnny Depp dock oh
yeah man whoa is it but is it I don't
know how the clearance works on that I
assume they they assume you think you
want to be in it well like the counter
doc obviously I'd never be like hey what
the hell man and you're never gonna
email Netflix I'm like hey you I didn't
give you my consent for this not only
that but there you go what what that
just did what that just did was
depressed me
my career was uh you're in the movie
you're in the [__] Joker you're in
that mood and it's like yeah if you
there there I am wait the Johnny Depp
dog depressed you well I mean that's I'm
in for a couple seconds just like that
joker you know that's all I'm just yeah
it could be worse [__] it could not be
in the Joker he could not be in the
Johnny Depp doc it can always be worse
hey dude I practice
gratitude I wake up before I even get
out of bed and I thank my creator for
everything I have gay
gay I hate when people do that yay you
know Hallmark card come on man I'm just
trying to I'm trying to open up can you
just give me a second please be grateful
you found this big whale all right let
me try it let me just try to be
sentimental and don't interrupt me all
right
I just want to say that's very important
to wake up
count your blessings gay
I don't like it man okay
trying to Express gratitude let me try
it again no and just let it sink into
your heart I'm trying to get to your
heart but can you do something original
I haven't heard I just want to thank
from everybody in this room George
you're doing an amazing job chin you
have been Old Faithful you're you're an
alcoholic and your liver is going to
have to be replaced but you have
dedicated yourself to us and you're
literally killing yourself for the gig
we didn't ask what nobody's asked you to
drink he just he just died
he died very peacefully and uh what's
the what's the address you would give
chin it'd be like this
um I just uh listen we love chin didn't
know him at all
um we've never had no idea
that many bodies under his house but
other than that we loved him and he was
a good man like the gigolo uh serial
killer chin surprised us all he liked to
fish he liked to camp and say thank you
for everyone for coming we do have
Korean barbecue in the back that's right
and that's something chin wanted he told
us he wanted that yep it's Korean it's
wagyu beef
that's Japanese God damn it you know if
there's no that's the joke
there you go that's Japanese I go I
always did that to Chin as well there
you go hope you guys are good that's
good dude that's a little tribute to
Chin good call back yep that's good
callback
we'd love you Chin Chin tried helping me
with my Asians went to Australia almost
better perfect not perfect this is
actually perfect timing I can't believe
you said that right now why because I
have a little game that I prepare for
you guys the game I like games games
Buffalo Wild Wings it's getting hot
yeah the NFL season is heating up and so
is your appetite do you like to watch
football with your buddies sitting
around the couch with nothing
genetically modified chicken wings
you've never seen a chicken this big
they're thick all right here we go all
right this is great that's a perfect
freaking segue that came naturally I
love it Cambodian I'm not gonna we have
it we have the rest of them I will get
Cambodia so this is actually we have a
list Korean Japanese Cambodian Filipino
to me chinese vietnamese Thai I think
Filipino spelled with a p but no that's
the Philippines okay Filipinos with us
is it all right come on tell an agent
piece of [__]
Buffalo Wild Wings we're going Asian we
have Korean Japanese Cambodian Filipino
chinese vietnamese and Thai wings
and taiween
Taiwanese and Thai wings
did you say Taiwanese no you stupid [__]
Thai wings okay we're gonna have to cut
this is not working this it's getting
Asian
so I mean if people want to play along
it's uh the options are Korean
Korean Japanese Cambodian which is
a Filipino chinese vietnamese and Thai
those are the options do we need a fun
intro song
Asian this is brought to you by Buffalo
Wild Wings name your Asian name your
Asian's perfect do you know your Asians
all right so you guys have uh markers in
your oh okay cup holders I wonder why I
had a Grace yeah me too why'd I get
great I meant that for Brian because
he's going great yours is brown she
doesn't switch it over that makes sense
and then uh all right so I just put the
number I'm gonna play one through seven
just put the corresponding on music no
it's language oh
which I'll be terrible at but then we
just pictures
next week name Eurasian next week yeah
pictures okay first one so remember just
corresponding Asian put the number down
which we which uh this would be number
one this is probably more well traveled
I feel like so here's number one I know
so but it's perfect because I'm a plus
nine Brian's more culture than all of us
honestly right and then but Brennan you
know uh we went across the pond you were
actually really good at picking if I see
them I'm good with faces No are you bad
with language no but when you heard the
language when you heard the language you
actually knew so here we go first one
name your agent Panda Express but don't
say it out loud just write it down
that's a robot okay right next hold on
hold on let me give me that one again
no yeah give me one more that's okay
all right number two
Jesus Christ
this might as well be alien stalking I'm
not hurting any of this dude damn did
you write it down yeah I didn't make it
easy on you believe me I love this game
I love this there's number three number
three
give me one sec
here we go
wait hold on did I say something about
Brendan they all have your names in it
just so you know okay oh my God you got
it yeah you're right down okay
whatever
number four ready
here's number four
it's not playing give me a sec here we
go
songs
Gago
the [__] called me scarb this is so
good you got it yeah all right I can't
wait to see how bad here's number five
that's great
we'll see
everybody got it yep number six
number seven yep last one
that's Japanese
all right so
um
I don't know
can we see her hold on
man I don't know now okay it's so tough
I don't know if I get it they all sound
exactly the same can we see her she's
[__] up let's see your charts
do you want us to hand them to you no
just don't just tell me if you're right
or wrong okay so the number one yeah
don't do this Georgie
see how many I got right Circle the ones
you got right bee okay Circle and big
number one
is Chinese Chinese got that one
did not get that number two
Ty got that one God damn it to the
camera teacher
number three
Vietnamese vimini's no that I knew
because I was at that that was I went
Cambodian but it's just oh okay number
four
Cambodian [__] really God damn it [__]
one right
number five
number four
number four was Cambodian ah it sounds
some Korean to me Korean I got
interesting Brian number six
Filipinos yeah I know Brian would get
that one did you get it Brian yeah nope
okay and that leaves number seven I'm
sure you guys got them Japanese I got
two right
I got one two three I got four right oh
damn but I [__] I would have gotten
the Vietnamese in Cambodian but that's
really easy to screw up
um Brian you get it seems like you
switched these no I switched at last
minute no you did it you crossed it out
it's fair but he would have won anyways
I showed it to you oh yeah
um oh yeah
Korean again yeah so you're number four
I hear Korean so easy number four was
what Filipino no wait no number four is
Cambodian let me hear four
and then let me hear
uh we don't want to keep going back over
here
hold up it's so weird
so name your Asian that's gonna be the
game that's um
all right here we go
oh that's Korean all day
I got Korean and Japanese I should have
known that I didn't listen properly damn
it and then at the end of the session
I put gdush in there but you guys that
was a dumb Mish that was a dumb mess the
Korean part yeah I mean I put a bunch it
at once so that's so good though no
problem from Cambodia uh Filipino not
really I don't know anybody Chinese I
should never have gotten [__] crazy
dumb Korean Japanese baby it's fine
Brian no it's not two for seven
great game thanks good job Jen
appreciate it let's take a little break
B let's do a little break man you've
waited all year and the time has finally
arrived college football is back and so
are the Traditions the tailgates the
great offers from our friends at
DraftKings Sportsbook and right now new
customers can score 200 in bonus bets
instantly when they bet just five
dollars on any college football bet you
get USC playing you better my CU Buffs
all season long you got Alabama Ohio
State Tennessee everybody's been good
this year kick off the season with
DraftKings Sportsbook download the app
now use code fighter new customers can
score 200 in bonus bets instantly when
they bet just five dollar rules on any
college football bet only on draftking
Sportsbook with the code fighter
gambling problem called one enter again
with New York called
8778 hope NY on text help NY 467 369 in
West Virginia visit
www.1800 gambler.net in partnership with
Hollywood casino at Charlestown Races
all games regulated by the West Virginia
Lottery please pay responsibly in
Connecticut is available for problem
gambling at
888-789-777 or visit
ccpg.org on behalf of Boot Hill Casino
and Resorts Kansas 21 and over in most
eligible States but age varies by
jurisdictions Eve draftkings.com
Sportsbook for details and state
specifically responsible gambling
resources bonus bets expire seven days
after issuance eligibility and deposit
restrictions apply terms at
sportsbook.draftkings.com football terms
DraftKings promo code fighter look man
you want something that's lower in net
carbs than all the other popular nuts
lower in carbs than 30 33 less than
almonds fifty percent less than cashews
you know when I was a kid a rich guy
gave me a macadamia nut and I thought
man one day
macadamia nuts have arguably the best
fat profile of any nut okay like an
avocado on steroids all right that means
that they are very good for you they are
promises is super expensive and they're
rare dude if you go to House of
macadamias what how do you know where
it's not they're one percent of the
market but they have cornered the market
they work vertically with 90 plus
Farmers dude if you tell me they dip
these in sugar-free chocolate I'm gonna
freak out they do white and dark and
milk chocolate it's delicious okay do
they have got do they have Macadamia
bars that are 45 Mac name or not yeah
they do yeah they do they got extra
virgin Macadamia Oil if you want to cook
with that buttery flavor I need a
discount B do you have a discount we
never run discounts how some macadamias
has a very special offer for our friends
for the friends of tfak okay for a
limited time they are gifting a free box
of macadamia snack bars one in each
flavor okay
I love in order and get 20 off go to
houseamacademias.com
tfak plus 20 off your entire order with
code tfak let us know what you think let
us know how you feel after you eat them
because they're the best things in the
world for satiating your hunger and
keeping you shredded enjoy those
macadamia nuts visit House of
macadamias.com tfak
and you get 20 off your entire order
with code tfak
name yo Asian
that was a great game that was good
we'll do games like that I love games
from time to time you never know guys
you never know that's what the trainer
says he's like he's like I go I'm done I
do 15 reps he goes give me five more and
then he's in my ear he goes expect the
unexpected and then whoops what's this
hey bro that aerodyne bike I've talked
about it hits me in my diamond of
Despair I call that area right here in
your chest that creates a a coward a saw
yeah and you get so tired you're like I
don't know if I can do this let me ask
you something airtime bikes been out
since the 80s you just became privy to
it well I've done it I did it once and
on it I think and I was like remember
dying and I was like oh I don't want to
do that anymore and uh I it might be the
best thing you can do for your cardio I
don't know there's other things you can
do but they're good never gets easy yeah
it's tough oh there's that new document
speaking of Doc uh Netflix docs there's
a new Doc on there called uh something
swamp but it's the Florida team that had
Aaron Hernandez on it uh Percy Harvin
Tim Tebow the Pouncey brothers and it
covers when
um the head coach got there when he
first started there and then they
recruited Tim Tebow they have Tim Tebow
in his high school days he was like the
normal recruit it's so good Urban Meyer
oh it's so good really oh it's good and
they show like Urban Meyer like his I
think his dad was in the military in the
Army his mom was in the Air Force so he
he goes I come from a military
background so I run a tight ship and
they're saying it was like when they
recruited guys like it's gonna be the
toughest thing you've ever done in your
life and they show like the workouts
they did it was so similar to CU we
didn't have the same talent but
toughness we were right there really it
just brings back some old memories of
the pain yeah and Tim Tebow and I forget
the other guy the linebacker they both
loved it and a lot of those other
players like straight from the hood
they're like what the hell is this yeah
we're like you mean running until you
drop and that kind of crazy it shows
them like throwing up like during we
call it dirty dozens at CU is it is it
mostly the running that kills you like
this it's everything no it's everything
it's everything and and and Urban Meyer
said he goes that those those kind of
workouts are designed to get people out
the team so you see people like throwing
up crying or my would have and he
couldn't do this anymore which is shame
but they have uh they would have him
wrestle they'd have a guy start on his
back a guy on top and you got to get up
[__] you're talking about five star
athletes you couldn't do that today but
I just made the guy injuries and kids
are [__] they call their parents they
call NCAA and well
um I think they're training kids
differently too now because because the
repetitive injuries and stuff
everything's different now not in a good
way kids are soft kids are so soft yeah
well they're just not tough anymore the
Spanish would disagree who the Spain the
Spaniards they're putting out some of
the best athletes oh are they yeah name
the best football player tennis soccer
they got amazing athletes and the reason
is they had these camps with kids but
like messy I know the thing well Messi's
very old school he came up but they all
came from they came here when he was
seven years old I'm just telling you
what what's Spanish what I'm telling you
you're talking about two [__] Sports
I'm talking about American Sports soccer
of [__] sporty there's tennis either
they are though no no what I'm saying
compared to American Sports football has
changed not for the better it's gotten
softer well what I'm saying is that what
what they find and the reason Spain's
been so successful is that they're
bringing these kids up a little bit
differently so if you have a kid who's
on who's 13 14 on a second Tommy John's
surgery it's like something's going on
there and what they're what they're
finding why would they have Tommy John
playing soccer Tommy John's surgery I'm
talking about you know the way Americans
were doing it and it's changing now from
pitching yes but but it's it's when
these kids specialize to this degree in
sports with their trophy dads and stuff
they are doing just one thing over and
over see that's a new age thing that's a
new age thing right so when we were kids
we played everything we had everything
now they're coming back to that but
that's what I'm saying now especially in
America kids are specializing like the
moms like oh he's going to the NBA he's
going to MLB so they play baseball and
football year round right they put every
other sports they don't no now they
don't but they're they're finding that
you need to come back when you're
younger to play all different
don't like when you specialize in one
thing right so they loved when a
football player had a wrestling
background like he was all state in high
school they'd love that because that kid
he's tough yep it's like also with um
with tennis so it's really interesting
the the kids that are like 12 and under
who are that good who are like ranked
nationally a lot of times a lot of times
just weren't going on to do anything in
the pros and it was just because they
just they were just brought up to get
burnt out burnt out all that it's also
tough and then it's tough no matter what
even if you're still coming it's just a
different thing yeah
because I watched the I was watching
this Asian uh the the Chinese uh kids
and their dad and mom are out there when
I tell you that these kids were eight
nine and ten and they were playing four
hours every day after after school four
hours it's like I that's too much
physically I think that's too much I
don't think it's too much if that's what
the kid wants to do he's obsessed with
it do it but it's one of the parents but
can your body take that yeah when I was
a kid yeah yeah all day all the same
thing all day football basketball all
day but you're doing a lot of Summer all
day all day yeah that's what we did
but the problem is when the parents and
then they have a specialty coach and
it's all they focus on and then it's not
fun for the kid yeah you're doing drills
and running it's like I don't know man
you're nine
you got it it's got to be like my son
was a gym I didn't ask him I don't ask
him in the gym he asked me every morning
can we go to the gym can we go to the
gym I never asked him he really goes
never it's up to him otherwise because
if you push them they're gonna you know
what kids do especially when they get
older they they he's self-motivated they
Rebel that's what you want oh this is
[__] crazy George you just sent me
these kids are incredible oh these are
kids punching each other two siblings
foreign
and the mom's like yeah so dumb
that little girl is bad dude she's tough
as [__] the way she punches my footwork
kids moving his head
yeah there's a bunch of videos of them
both signed deals with one Championship
yeah I got some issues with that but
yeah yeah I can't once you hit getting
hit in the head that can't be good no
yeah I don't know what the movies
because even with football it's like
kids are starting later as far as tackle
football what do you think outside
with tackle football yeah like what do
you think like what how old were you
when you were playing tackle football
six
um would you uh
knowing about CTE what is what do you
feel about that that's my thing what do
like are you kind of on the fence no I'd
let if my kid wants to do it I'd sign
him up for it no problem but the problem
is now because America's So Soft it's
tough to find a little league tackle
football and that's all flag football
like you sign up for flag football sit
down playing football like no you're not
that's no yeah you're playing gravis
that's not football when do they learn
the fundamentals when are they getting
the tackle like Middle School no yeah I
think the the league that he's in will
start tackling fifth grade
it's a little late but I mean
how old are they and then they're like
10 right 10. fifth he's going to Second
so it'll be like 11 or 12 probably
what's this I just Googled when do kids
play tackle football they're just
suggesting practice at age 12 and 14. I
against that would it make a difference
in how they play the game you know I
mean 14 is a pretty still pretty young
to start tackling right uh no of course
14 you're behind the ball they're 14
where you're fresh you can catch ice
cream it's tough
is it stuff yeah because I know tennis
that's that's actually late well that's
like you can't unless you're a complete
freak yeah I mean
with tennis you cannot if you start then
at 14. you're never gonna you're never
because those kids have grooved their
stroke and they don't do anything wrong
like I think if the kid's an athlete the
only thing at 14 if he's not used to get
like taking the hits and it's like a
tough sport then he might not be for him
but also at 14 maybe we can he's a
little tougher so I think there's pros
there's definitely some freaks out there
that's but the CT doesn't bother me if
you look at the stats no yeah now you
look down in the South how they have
kids doing like Oklahoma drill when
they're like eight like probably not
that like we don't need all the hitting
yeah like like the way I was raised you
know Monday through Friday hitting all
the time Oklahoma yeah that's not the
that's not the way hey just not
concussions it's just you don't need to
do it beat these kids up like maybe hit
twice a week other days work on skills
yeah and I feel like if you're not built
like you are like like to take that kind
of punishment [__] man it's it's just a
matter of time before you're [__] if
you're hitting all the time like that no
because the skill the guys who aren't
built like me the skilled positions good
luck getting those kids yeah
what the pros what do they do scrimmage
twice a week
in Camp yeah what do you mean in Canada
during season season they don't touch
they don't they touch each other not
till Sunday yeah so what are they doing
they're just running they're just
running they know how to play football
they're Pros they're running plays big
college programs do the same thing too
what are they doing watching tape
running yeah they're doing all that and
then they have the game plan for the
week so they're just so they go over
that yeah there's no hitting during the
week but college programs like Michigan
Ohio State they don't hit during the
season anymore at that level you should
know how to play yeah and they just get
prepared for this for the actual but
what about what about in the preseason
during practice scrimmage all that stuff
uh preseason yeah they'll do some
one-on-one stuff they'll hit so so
there's rules now in the NCAA you can't
do two days anymore we used to do three
a days can't do two days anymore but it
what I like about Dion Sanders changing
the culture at Sea because you got to be
[__] tough man yeah at the end of the
day you got to be tough that's what the
University of Florida was that's what we
were Ohio state Alabama the SEC teams
there's just they have the best talent
but they're also the toughest teams when
the going gets rough they don't crumble
that's why
just showed a clip they're they're
they're doing a hitting drill something
or the scrimmagen and two guys start to
fight and some guys come in some guys
are just standing there and Dion goes
what are you doing if one fights all you
[__] fight nobody's in trouble for
fighting you'll be in trouble for not
fighting wow yeah and people like you
believe this I'm like oh thank God so
what do you mean I'm not saying two guys
could show one guy from the defense
defense let's say it's a receiver and a
cornerback and they start scuffling and
three of the DBS come in and get his
back and nobody for the offense does it
yeah Dion was like what are you doing if
one of you fight you all fight I love
that yeah that's team cohesion yeah it's
like what are you doing I mean that's my
that's my [__] that's my skin he's
like you're not gonna get in trouble for
fighting you get in trouble if you don't
if you just let your guy get beat that's
old school but I was raised that way
like if you you are friends but you and
our friends and you're gonna fight can
you imagine if you got in a fight with
with somebody on like in a situation
imagine that I'm like hey bro and you're
just running can you I mean even if
you're in the wrong I'm like we'll talk
about it later unless you have your back
like that's right you might be wrong but
you're still my friend I got it now I
got now we're both in it you [__]
[__] I'll yell at you later we gotta
be Network games are over
in the dock
and then you see all these guys coming
it's like that's how it should go for
everybody in this
space that's how I am I mean that's how
I am I you know I I will if I die with
masculinity okay I'm down for my I'm
down for my [__] if if you and I are
friends y'all suck your dick I mean
that's how it is if you need it I
appreciate that hey whatever it takes
bro about my buddy of mine's uh uh his
his wife has some health issues and um
she got covered but it was real bad for
her
she almost died
and uh he he said to me he goes you're
the only guy who called me every day
and I was like
well I don't need a medal for that I
call that what you do that's the mother
of your kids she was in real dire
certain obviously I'm gonna call my
friend to make sure everything's okay I
don't think of that as something I'm not
going above and beyond that's just me
picking up yeah
I'll do it if that's rare
right yeah up I'll kill her I no that's
not I don't that's not what I meant text
me because that's not what I meant I'm
not gonna hide a body well you know I
have a few friends who will no I mean I
have two I would too when I say well
at everyone in here at chin I don't know
I feel like you'd snitch on us a little
bit I'm the one that probably would be
the one having you guys help me find the
body Shin's Korean he's down for the
cause Koreans are hardcore [__]
yeah dude remember that Koreans might
Mike my Taekwondo cheese is Korean
hardcore Korean said to me he goes he
told a story he said I you know it's
like a parable but he he was talking
about your friends a lot of your you
think you have friends who don't a lot
of these people are not your friends
because he saw me hanging out with
people and he goes just be careful
because you like a lot of people I
should have listened to them [__]
long time ago and he said you know um
there's that story about the the father
said you think you have friends and they
took a pig and they put it under a sheet
it was bloody and they went to every one
of his friend's houses and said we gotta
help you got to help us hide this body
and they were all like [__] out and
close the door and it was one guy I said
I'll help you and he goes that's your
only friend well that's your dumbest
friend that might be your dumbest friend
but it's your friend he's dumb but he's
your friend but yeah that's done with
[__] and throwing away his life
because you killed somebody for no
reason it's just the mishandling of a
corpse buddy that's a weird thing to do
but if you came to me and said I [__]
up I had to pull somebody's head off
their spine I got a little Bam Bam on
him yeah I'd be like oh [__] dude no
there's a few people oh I was like ah
well and then I help you hide the body
and then I would call the cops right
away the minute you left I'd be like
guys this is awkward you're like dude
I'd like to I'd like to make an
anonymous tip I need 30 of your salary
oh dude I watched this uh you know the
gigolo serial killer you know I'm into
that stuff I looked more into it what's
interesting about that you know he could
have been caught
15 years ago you know they had all this
evidence the guy the Long Island guy
yeah they had all this evidence forever
and here's where it gets [__] here
here's where it's interesting so the
chief of police there was really into
escorts as well and knewed him and knew
he was doing this stuff but he thought
if that guy got caught back then that it
would have put a spotlight on the police
force so he made sure that he wasn't
caught so one of the guys there to the
chief of police chief police involved he
was he was banging some of those girls
oh he was notoriously no he at the the
like the meetings the you know the
celebrations like Christmas uh parties
whatever he would bring escorts and they
just knew he was really into escorts so
what this guy did is he hid all this
stuff so it didn't chase back to him so
so one of the ladies one of the escorts
that the gigolo uh guy killed one of the
escorts
she got into this guy came over to her
house and she had a roommate and she
called her roommate because he was
getting really aggressive she's like hey
this guy something's up he seems like a
goddamn sociopath get over here he busts
in the door he was I walked in there's
this GI he's like six seven so he was
like he was the he this is the cop no no
this is this is just the the escort's
roommate and he goes right away I was
like oh this guy's problem he kind of
[__] him up and kicked him out but he
said the guy was just cold-blooded like
drove off just staring at him she goes
missing a month later he goes to the
place like I know exactly who did it he
looks like this he drives this car he
lives here
they hit all that far so then they then
they found her body right and then they
found more bodies and they found like
four bodies and it was the winner and so
they get the dogs the sniffing Dogs Out
the chief of police pulled him back
because they they can't smell anything
the winner
like what the [__] you talking about
what are they lifeguards they don't work
in the winter and they're like yeah the
dogs don't work in the winter so he
pulled it off so all the evidence
decayed all the body all the evidence
decayed so when they went back and found
multiple multiple bodies they couldn't
find the evidence because he didn't want
to trace back this piece of [__] yeah
man so there's a whole thing I didn't I
don't know if that chief police is
involved in the murders but he
definitely masks everything because
everybody around that town knew there
was this guy
and the chief police made sure he didn't
get caught James Burke Jimmy Burke was
picked up in Suffolk County
power see so but now that he's not the
chief of police that's coming out but
when he's Chief when he's running [__]
he made sure this guy didn't get caught
and the shame is they could have saved a
lot of lives
what the hell interesting right was the
guy gay though I thought the he was
listening for a gay guy or something or
dude no no no only chicks man come on
follow the case huh I thought I saw gay
no no not far from it oh my God that's
him only one after women I mean I mean
dude dude crazy right you can't see this
is what I mean like you cannot do that
you can't [__] do that man man when
you're right you're right but you know
what I mean like you you have to live
with yourself like if you're dealing
with no but think if you're that Chief
please if you would have got caught off
the first murder you save how many times
so he had houses and I think ears are in
Seattle and Vegas too and there's women
that are missing there so they think he
was killing in Vegas in [__] Seattle
who's who's that go go back up who's
this guy that's the chief police oh
who's the other guy that was walking
then that's chief police too the same
guy huh this guy that's chief police
that's him now oh okay that he's no
longer chief police so now they're
looking into it but there's like
eyewitness who are like dude we knew
this was the [__] guy we knew exactly
he drove a Chevy Avalanche a green one
they gave him the exact details of the
car he drove the [__] serial killer
would park it on the street like there
he is dude that's so embarrassing you
are the you are the chief of police
so bad dude I look I looked up houses in
Gigolo Beach that thing is look at nice
uh I mean you don't want to be an escort
down there but that thing is Burke did a
Bare Bones investigation into the serial
murder case freezing out the FBI and
other agencies working on discovery of
11 bodies 11. how about dude how obvious
is it when they have the smelling dogs
because yeah they can't work in the
winter let's wrap those things up dude
he was like what you cannot lie in
certain you just can't you've got to
just take the take the pain or it's
gonna but this is this is where my my my
skeptical hip Wives come up my spice ins
go off is
he was so scared that it was gonna look
bad on him because he's in the escorts
that seems that's wait a minute I feel
like he's going back to that that's what
I saw Brendan it gets thicker disgrace
Long Island police chief James Burke who
botched Gigolo beat serial killer Rex
humerman's probe is seen leaving jail
after being busted for offering mail
undercover codes
that's what I saw I thought you're
saying the gigolo Beach
no this guy's a freak your dick her
titty he don't care his issue is is I
think he's more involved than we know
but he was in jail for 46 months yeah
ain't [__] that's a long time Bubba
uh oh so he was he went to jail
but why was he in jail for 46 months for
beating a man oh Jesus see I think he's
involved in the murders
I've seen this too much dude I watched
way too much First 48 all the serial
killer dogs this guy's involved
so I bet he killed him now I'm confused
because he was getting um
so he he and just guys no no no and
women and women mainly when so he was
just trying to suck a guy's wiener there
maybe for money I don't know but he he
also him in that Gigolo Beach guys had
this similar prostitutes they they were
in the same Circle okay
wow and he was running prostitutes I
think he was hiring them for the other
guys or was it just for himself the
gigolo yeah oh police chief for himself
but they were saying that he's so
involved with the escort business and he
knew that that was the serial killer if
I get money ah they think he was
involved in some of the murders that's
what that's what I think you do you
think the guy that got went to prison
for four years for beating a man I don't
think he would have been because that
serial killer [__] is deep dark
weird and he hit and he hit all the
evidence because he didn't want to get
caught but because serial killer more
women sin is the idea that he put
himself first over the lives of these
women so that so you don't think it's so
you think it's extreme to think that he
somehow is involved I do I think I don't
no first of all I think serial killers
they say in Shawshank obtuse no I think
they act alone that's not true uh Summer
of Sam did not act alone he did no he oh
my God bud no he didn't yeah he did no
that's well documented it's son of Sam's
Sam's son of friends
I'm telling you off on this
I'm telling you there's multiple son of
Sam's that's not conspiracy
no no there's multiple people that he
was involved with and the reason why he
never snitched on them is because the
the group that he was with told me
they'd kill his family so he took the
hit there's multiple people involved
that son of Sam's it's son of Sam's not
Son of Sam son of Sam's Berkowitz did
not work alone
uh can you look up did Berkowitz work
type in Son of Sam's Sam's plural
you're stepping in my pool now Daddy I
know and you're not knowledgeable honest
I got real skeptical hippo eyes on this
but let me ask you this be when's the
last time you looked in the Son of Sam
probably in the 90s let's be honest yeah
but I just don't think so
yeah I don't see that Bubba I think
you're full of [__] he pleaded guilty to
eight shootings began in New York in
1976 so who is he working with sir I
mean that it was a it was a whole it was
a whole team I'm telling you it's like
did you read a book like that no it's
it's a there's a book on it B there's a
documentary on Netflix called son of
Sam's and even the chief of police who
arrested him agreed that there's
multiple killers
I'm telling you I know you don't believe
in any conspiracies that's why you and
Sam get into it this one's my conspiracy
because Google tells you kill day people
he he admits to the people that he
killed okay but he didn't kill all eight
the Son of Sam the the son of Sam's uh
Center of Darkness the infamous series
of a man obsession with the case one
man's Obsession all right brought to the
end Manhunt history the city he was at
the mercy of so-called Son of Sam serial
killer terrorization I'm mostly in love
his lands 24 hours for confessing brutal
crimes all right anybody who grew up in
New York City this is right here argues
that probably did not act alone
the the chief of police who was involved
in it admits that he didn't act alone
yeah that's great
I think you're uh I think you're taking
some uh what's it called poetic license
buddy no there's all sorts of
information on this video I like that
you want to believe that and I'm I
appreciate it but I think he probably
click on that trailer to educate right
the problem is you know what you are
you're like my dad when you watch CNN
the murders stop when they arrested him
what's up didn't the murder stop when
they arrested him he was shooting people
with a 44 magnum so whoever was doing
that was that was David Berkowitz I
don't think he had a he was yeah I was I
don't think he was meeting with other
guys going let's kill everybody sure
okay did they catch anybody else I'm
telling you got to look into it
and you fall you full-blown conspiracy
guy now this is not against that's
what's an alarming domination because
when I asked you when's the last time
you looked into it you said the 90s
killer on the loose in New York why do
the police not investigate more
yeah that uh that's um that's that looks
like a well that's a great way to get
people to watch the documentary but uh
sorry uh I'm not trying to convince you
I don't give a [__] yeah but I just I'm
not like Sam I literally don't care I
don't think that cops would carry I
would agree no of course because they're
so by the book especially New York Times
yeah sorry buddy I'm with you man I mean
I like that you're basing it on a
documentary I'm not beat there's
multiple there's so many books on this
yeah you just don't you don't know
that's why I'm trying to entertain this
right okay it's like me talking about
NFL football I know a lot about give me
ask me one [__] question about NFL
football name the starting quarterback
for the Tennessee Titans for the
Tennessee Titans name the quarterback
they drafted what college you came from
right now
Lamar Jackson there you go you know it's
uh like I'm not it's not like Sam I'm
not gonna argue with you ask me one more
question
um name the running back for the Colts
who wants to be traded can you not be a
dick about these [__] specifics this
is like current yeah but you're asking
me like super current stuff the the
All-Pro running back for the
Indianapolis Colts who wants to be
traded and it looks like he's going to
the Dolphins what what who does Ezekiel
Elliott play for now they're not the
Giants anymore not the Cowboys I mean
anymore Lisa Giants plays for I believe
he plays he might play for I know he got
traded and he might play foreign
running backs I know this running backs
don't have a long life in the NFL
very cool man 10 years is a long time
right
six years Alone six years long time but
it used to be it used to be they'd play
for a lot longer right no no Tony door
said those guys yeah drama from the 70s
yeah
I don't know man but you proved my point
though right
yeah I'm afraid your son of Sam's stuff
is uh
it's what you want to believe sure
yeah you really think there was more
yeah 100 yeah
I definitely think uh Berkowitz killed
people not all of them great people
right well I only killed all eight you
definitely kill people The Killing
stopped though once he got arrested nope
the the shooting so they didn't stop
there's more killings there's more
killings well I mean New York's gonna
have killings all the time but sure I
know right
I promise I'm not I'm not even trying to
I don't care if you think that he was by
himself but I'm saying it's fine the
specific profile like uh where where
this is a serial killer who is matching
a certain pattern I think that stopped
after he got arrested didn't he you're
assuming that he's a serial killer which
would mean three or more right he said
he didn't shoot three he got arrested
for eight he had he confessed to eight
killings according to no according to
that he said I didn't kill all of them
but according to that he said he
confessed to eight killings according to
the auto glass chin bro well that later
on they said and you know no that was
yeah videos from a year later so I
didn't pull the trigger no no that video
was not from a year later that's when he
has gray hair no no that's a long time
later again
it looks like good fiction like I'm
intrigued to watch it I like it I get I
get it but I just and all the books
written on it you know what I'm you know
what I'm um you know what I'm kind of
grading against is that there's a lot of
this going around about everything
and nowadays you can spin a narrative
about anything right just anything that
we talk about whether it's the the
political point you can do that you can
do that on Truth as well you can do that
on anything so let me ask you this piece
since you know serial killers how many
people Charles Manson kill
zero
not true really nope
I don't think he killed anybody he had
directed people to kill people
he killed one who he shot a guy on spawn
Ranch
um
okay
but not a lot it was like he had that
cult he's not a serial killer
but he's the most infamous serial killer
I think that's like when you look in the
Manson case like and it's nobody's fault
you got to really be balls deep and we
look at man's case you think right the
family killed all these people that's
the end of the story that's not the end
of the story
the guy who's a legit expert on it and
you look at the book that Helter Skelter
book with uh forget the guy's name
pelusi or something like that I forget
his name but you look into that book
that the the district attorney the
prosecutor had a whole narrative the
whole beatles thing all that I think
right I think that what this is what I
know about Manson tell me if I'm correct
Charles Manson I I know that they think
he might have been part of those MK
Ultra experiments 100 that's document
okay so the CIA at one point actually
did use LSD and other psychedelics on
unsuspecting people even people that
went into brothels and stuff this all
came out in the church the church report
do you know who else they did that with
um the Unabomber yes so so a lot of
these people were you know they wanted
to see how psychedelics would work but
Charles Manson also like grew up in what
he called the hallways of always he was
a really badly abused and grew up in
juvenile detention things and all that
stuff his mom sold him for a uh eight
ounces of beer when he was a kid Jesus
and so you you see this guy has been
destroyed he tries to be a musician not
terrible not bad I think he was hanging
out for a while or for a second with
people in the beginning in that uh hold
the Beach Boys The Laurel canning
community right yeah yeah so then that
doesn't work out and he kind of goes out
and creates sort of this semi-cult he
gets about he had the cult before that
he had to call before that and he's
charismatic he's got a thing going he's
and then these young people get these
young kids get sort of brainwashed he
wants to create a race war
and gets them to go and says we've got
to do something Sensational and blame it
on the blacks so then he has his these
women and these men who are his
followers go to I think uh they try to
go to one house that didn't work out
then they went to Sharon Tate's house
was first right but they it was they
thought it was Roman Clancy's house
right but why did they want to do it to
him because he was a famous director
because he's famous yeah and then they
killed basically was it everybody in the
house everybody they stabbed everybody
including Sharon Taylor Sharon Tate and
the the here to the Folger Coffee Filter
company and the number one like stylist
in all of Hollywood oh so how many
people did so they hit three houses no
that's all in the same house so Sharon
Tate was killed with the here to Folger
the lady her boyfriend uh Sharon Tate's
friend who used to be her boyfriend
um though like basically the housekeeper
was killed as well and then also the
hairdressers at the Sebring so it was
the biggest [__] on the planet and
then they wrote pigs and all that stuff
from blood right and then
when they did all this [__] I'm sure and
the next night they went to the LA
Bianca house in uh Los Feliz and they
killed them too killed uh it was a a
husband and wife they just killed him
yep stabbed him and and tex walked and
did all the killing Tex Watson one guy
yep he was the one well he he was the
main guy who did the majority like the
bad killing then he'd tell them they
have to do it too yeah
the text Watson's the real real bring up
text Watts he's a real bad real social
he's still alive he's in prison in Texas
yeah he that's him he's he's the he's
the main culprit here he's the really
bad one scumbag bad bad guy yeah what a
[__] scumbag and what was his deal he
just was a sociopath who just wanted to
kill people probably yep man what a
[__] bad guy
what a harsh he was the one that did all
the the main killing
ugh
and so um why did they go along with it
what was it about Charles Manson that
made them go along with it I mean you
know Court reader lost trying to please
him yeah they thought he was like the
second coming to Jesus because he'd give
him acid and then pretend he was getting
crucified and then looked like Jesus so
they thought he was able to talk to
Jesus yeah you get enough dumb [__] out
there to do [__] like that well some of
these girls some of those girls are 14
15 16 years is that right they were that
young yeah one was 16 when she committed
the murders oh [__] 16. you're a kid she
just got out of prison you're a kid a
month ago and your brain isn't even
developed no you don't know yeah
how about how about one of the followers
it was this young girl she was like 15
14 and the dad was like this ain't right
we got to put a stop this he goes to
talk Charles to like beat Charles Manson
up
in that meeting gets converted joins the
family the dad's like this guy's awesome
I'm gonna stay
normal dude nine to five Blue Collar guy
that's how Charming that [__]
get lost and you don't have a family or
a dad to kick you into [__] gear
whatever it is that's what all these
people did have they they come from
family but you know and they weren't the
best looking right you know five twos
make a ten that's Charlie's let me see
the girls bring the girls they're not
good looking they were not one girl was
like hideous I had a mustache but
Charlie Charlie Charles Manson Charlie
buddy of mine Charlie would go you're
beautiful she's like what
like one straight up had a mustache
they're not terrible the one on the far
left the one on the far right just got
out of prison
the one on the far left was that's them
smiling as they're being arraigned yep
and then they shave their heads and uh
carved uh
crosses on their foreheads because
Charlie did it oh Jesus Christ seriously
see one on the far left oh she's not how
about the one in the middle it's not a
great look huh one of the far right part
of the best punk rock band five twos
make a ten though
oh that's not a good look at all yeah
and uh she just got out
look at that is dude look at that
look at how old she is she went in when
she was [__] 16 dude 16 years old
kids
not crazy you spend your whole life in
jail
look at that
that was during the trial there in LA
they're outside on the street
you can understand how America at this
point was like because people were like
what the [__] is going on with these
people they're just killing people we
got to do something about that look at
that
yeah what's great you know Steve McQueen
was supposed to be at the the Sharon
Tate house that night but he was like he
met some girl on the way I was like I'm
gonna get my dick Jesus what shout out
to her wow shout out to her then he died
of cancer anyway at 37. but he kept the
gun with him the entire time did he yeah
smart but even before this kept a gun on
there there's so cool they're saying
that's why it was good if he was there
because he always had a gun oh that
would have been he's a real man's man a
real man yeah he would have shot those
[__] right in the face yep not a
bummer man that's when you want a gun
you want to be now that house is down
that the the Sharon Tate house they
knocked it down they rebuilt it it's
like 30 million it's on the market right
now 30 million house is amazing okay so
who's the worst sir we're serial killer
of all time no no
no I'm John Wayne Gacy what he did to
those boys and stuff no because he at
least at least John I mean they're all
terrible but John Wayne Gacy at least
killed like kids who were like 16 17 18
19 in their 20s and they all worked no
never younger BTK killed families and
tied up little kids and murdered little
kids a little kid you can't do I can't
hear about it I can't even hear about it
bdk's the worst there are some there's
the evil of the evil so I mean it's
horrible ptk is awful man when I when
you can kill kids and then he'd make the
sister watch as the emergency
is the OWN circular I can't get into
because he hurts kids yeah yeah if it's
a dog oh I can if it's adults adults
whatever is it's still all bad but it's
interesting energy when it's kids I'm
out I wish we could figure out a way to
like have a scan where you could see
people's bad brain you'd be like you got
Bad Brains you got bad intentions you
got bad intentions you know like there's
it's a very rare person who's that into
evil that bad gets off on evil those
people well that's why they need to die
The Night Stalker is interesting because
he legit like uh obsessed over Satan so
did uh Berkowitz yeah son of Sam's that
whole cult was uh satanic cult but yeah
uh The Night Stalker uh Richard Ramirez
legit had you know carved in the yeah
the Pentagon where the [__] it is quite
literally he thought he was a soldier of
Satan yeah so he thought by killing
people you'd get him into hell that's it
he's hopefully in hell all right let's
uh let's move on from serial killer talk
sorry everybody
you got a PP yeah I'll take over I'll
I'll keep I'll keep it going
what are we doing are we rolling still
if you want I don't mind let's roll what
else we got we have uh any uh current
events or whatnot by the way while we're
talking everybody and you were listening
this you're in San Antonio anywhere near
that you come out to the LOL Comedy Club
because I'm bringing Heat
Wise Guys number one and two
I had my uh son do a promo for me I saw
it it was very funny on your Instagram
yeah watch go to my Instagram
mm-hmm
I said come up with a promo for me
look at your cat there's cat
shout out to cat I miss her
is it here or this one right there
well I guess are you guessed I've never
listened to any of your standouts you
listen to everybody else and you don't
listen to me um
[Music]
Jim Gaffigan uh Sam Gretzky Sam Gretzky
I didn't know what that is so use the
jumper Jim Gaffigan Anthony Jeselnik and
Sam gretzki and you're my son come up
with a good ass or a statement for my
shows and uh
uh this weekend and my shows in Salt
Lake City if you if your throat doesn't
hurt after this
you get 500.
Mike why would my comedy hurt people's
throat guys
[Music]
you you get you your rent is waiting for
a month
you don't [__] your pants
were you in San Antonio are you staying
at hotel Emma yes I am did you talk to
him yeah my favorite I love that place
the best oh yeah you stayed there George
you remember that yeah you can tell I'm
a baby they give him the presidential
suite really got his own pool and [__]
roads there you go
I love it what do you got chin all right
first one is just uh John Fury
oh this is wow let me fill Brian in so
uh Logan Paul's fighting Dylan Dennis
and KSI is fighting Tommy Fury so that's
why big Fury's there the dad Logan Paul
is fighting Dylan Dennis in boxing in
boxing not Jiu Jitsu that'd be a
nightmare the issue is is Dylan dance
has been selling this thing going at
Logan Paul's fiance anyways so the point
is is Dylan dance has been going so hard
in the paint yeah which I don't condone
I don't like it I don't either but and I
just don't think the juice is worth the
squeeze for Logan because you beat up
Dylan's whatever but now like the
reputation of his fiance's like when he
posts about her and the guys she's
hooked up with it's getting like three
million views yeah like it but that's
his only selling point so they do this
press conference it's kind of a [__]
show they don't do a Face-Off what's
interesting is Mike Perry's the backup
fighter
Logan you have problems if Dylan doesn't
show up and Mike Perry steps in oh my
you mean Mike Perry boxing with Logan
yeah man that's tough that's tough fight
for Logan really
well one one's a real fighter right Mike
Perry's a [__] he's a
[__] but boxing's a little
different
let me Mike Perry boxes
he's a bare knuckle Champion you think
Logan beats Mike pair in boxing I never
said that I'm just asking I'm very
intrigued with your I'm I'm that'd be
all that'd be a nightmare for Logan it
would be a nightmare Logan why Mike
Perry would be a nightmare for for Jake
Paul because because Mike Perry really
yeah Mike Perry yeah recently yes but I
I and and as a multiple time beat
Michael Venom page beat your boy Luke
rockhold ask him how good Mike Perry is
yeah Mike his teeth out I just like this
conversation I'm liking this see this I
don't think it I don't think it happened
this is intriguing as [__] to me though
I never would have picked Mike Perry and
now you just said it you think Mike
Perry so Mike Perry Jake Paul fight be a
tough fight for Jason Jake Paul's got
his hands full yes
now it's a better fight but Logan Paul
Mike I don't like
Logan Logan just doesn't have the
experience for a Mike Perry Mike Perry's
gonna make her that's all he does he's
got he's going to Barrel forward and
just start making a dog and he can hit
hard right he can hit hard yeah and he
can take a punch Mike's not afraid of uh
no Mike's a dog yeah but let me see now
Dylan Dylan Dan is his strictly Jiu
Jitsu and and he's new to boxing though
yeah but he has MMA fights
he's fighting Bellator how do you do who
wins yeah how's it striking not good not
good
I would say yeah yeah logoing strange
you say that he wouldn't show up for the
Logan Paul fight he's been notoriously
known for not taking fights and not
showing up really yeah he had a fight
booked with KSI who's also on this fight
card fighting Tommy Fury and he didn't
show up to that he didn't show it just
didn't show yeah very strange
I haven't seen this what is it chin
we'll just play for you yeah
why is
time so Fury
people's personal problems
let's get a [__] ball rolling
the education
before I do it John John
can anybody question who I am here
what's what's he mad about
what's he so mad about who knows
right before this Logan was about to try
to tell a personal story about Dylan
danis's parents using both of them by
name and then John interrupted them look
at the size he was like enough buckets
Dad look at how much bigger he is than
Dylan Dennis Jesus Christ massive sons
[__] Tyson my gosh that's where Tyson
got the hype from and he just got mad
He's also old school because he doesn't
like he's like he's old school like us
like when he gets personal he's like all
this personal [__] I'm not here for
right is he my son to beat anybody no I
do things
step up and go stop this this is this is
this is low class you need to you need
that but then he takes it low too by
kicking over the table and stuff right
well yeah there's a good well he's a
gypsy don't [__] around
just talking about Logan Paul's fiance I
don't like that I don't I don't think
that's I think it sucks and I think it's
[__] up for to say that to about about
a woman like he doesn't know her like
she's she she was doing her thing okay
yeah who the [__] wasn't doing it I mean
yeah and she's very attractive seems
cool yeah I don't like well it's his
fiancee leave her the [__] out of it bro
that's the thing with these kids now
there's no line they don't cross like
Jake Paul when Daniel was talking [__]
to him like oh you're messing up Dana
these kids it's all they do but yeah I
don't like it they don't come from our
our cut of cloth it's just a different
animal like these kids can bring
people's kids in their family itself I
don't like it yeah I'm so not with it I
know I wish they would stop I don't know
I don't care how young and how how how
uh trendy it is it's [__] up to me
it's just I know for Dylan it's what's
getting eyeballs it's like when boys are
getting eyeballs I think he got like I
think he got Plus 400k on Twitter or
something like that what's he saying
he's just showing pictures of her with
dudes and going another one here's
another one top of the morning here's
another one and they'll be like damn
this guy
Dylan is saying that these are all
public pictures he's not doing he's not
even saying anything on the post that's
Dylan's excuse but then Logan Paul says
that some of them are you know
photoshopped and this and that so
they're going back and Logan says I
don't care what happened but I'm in love
with her yeah
you know what you know who's winning
Logan yeah Logan's winning in general
so if that fight happens who do you guys
have
if I 100 have uh Logan Paul and because
I'm rooting for him after that that's
[__] up boxing yeah Logan yeah Logan's
Logan
is athletic as [__] and he can finish
you see the stuff he's doing in WWE have
you seen this stuff he's incredible yeah
he's not just wrestling he's WWE
substance
he's [__] athletic man he is amazing
that kid is that I put him I think he's
just as athletic as [__] or more as
Dylan danis even though Dylan danis has
been a pro athlete you know or I don't
know we'll see I think I think I think
it's gonna be interesting I don't know
how much athleticism doesn't win fights
right that's true how much is he
recognize boxing is the question yeah I
don't know I don't care how athletic
Logan is um it's more about boxing he's
bigger a lot bigger than Dylan isn't he
yeah yeah how big is Dylan Dylan's
fights at 170 but walks probably at 200.
yeah I mean they're similar Logan's a
lot taller more muscular
and Logan's been focused on boxing now
don't dance is world champion
belt round belt oh Brown not black belt
black belt absolute's got a little dicey
we had a tough run there and he's had
some injuries but Jiu Jitsu world class
men don't get it twisted but this isn't
changed or is that what does that mean
brown but he's he won the his his run at
Brown belt's like a store like one of
the best ever but when he got to Black
he got a little dice in the absolutes
but he's a world champion but yeah yeah
killer killer when it comes to jiu jitsu
yeah
oh he [__] wrestled with Gordon Ryan
yeah oh [__]
yeah no he's as legit as a cowboy comes
Jiu Jitsu okay Shields beat him with
Jake's a monster
next event yeah all right so let's just
jump over well let's just jump with this
one so Ted Cruz I guess he saw a tweet
about a shark in the freeway this is the
same thing he thought it was in L.A
going around like wow and he's like
what'd he say let me see he goes holy
crap
but holy crap he thought it was real
yeah big cat from Barstool who's a silly
dude goes friend of mine in La just took
this picture on the 405 and yes all news
and media Outlets you have permission to
use this this is wild clearly he's
trolling it's big cat he's hilarious Ted
Cruz but holy crap is that is real
an actual great white floating down the
405 and then he goes
I'm told this is a joke Nelly you never
know and everyone please stay safe from
the storm otherwise just funny how about
Brennan sending us pictures of his of
his road yeah the corner they're
starting to fix it
now there is a strip thank God thank God
somebody asphalt came off
scared though right oh you have to go
slowly over that but I mean it is a
problem isn't that weird though and who
do you call who do you call I know it's
all the city they're like whatever dude
yeah there's a little bit the asphalt
was the road was gone taken away some of
the road was gone now now don't say the
road was gone there was a tiny strip in
the beginning yes from the rain yeah a
little bit but I told you
who do you call
it's dangerous can we play the video you
cool with it uh no all right I don't
feel seeing where I live yeah exactly
all right let's go to
are you guys aware who this guy is Troy
Hawk
oh he's a greeter I think he's the one
of the funniest things going on right
now so I'll just play it for you I'd
love to get him on the pipe dude he
would be amazing can we reach out to him
yes reach out to him clearly a man with
an eye for detail so there's him in the
street compliments people very confident
strive
Compliments are simple but not easy
trust me you have a marvelous weight
distribution between your feet sir good
easy shift especially for us present
company included I can give them and do
but I can't take
oh Fair I'll be oh come on come on man
doesn't mean I don't love it a Yorkshire
compliment that's casting guard
sincerely appreciating something someone
has made an effort on will make their
day
so you're an aquamarine blue jeans
filled with dreams yes you are
you doing a wonderful job at a tricky
set of circumstances
you're welcome you look like a painting
you're just sitting there it's fantastic
the more unique the more bespoke the
more devastatingly effective your Vibe
is a genius artist turn creative
safe and stylish
but also capable enough to deal with
anything that's worrying you you have
skin tools earning energy
human eye beef and sunset
love it
wisdom should be cast in marble
see we both feel like we've had a coffee
I love your lap there's another one so
much there's a this is the last one oh
good okay just this is where he greets
uh Man City soccer players you have
fabulously symmetrical facts
absolutely symmetrical face
you're very welcome
[Music]
you have clear eyes and fabulous skin
you're clearly a master of hydration
soldiers back smash
guy is the best welcome to training camp
says any doubts just ask yourself what
would Yan Moby do
oh
studying that photo the boss that bone
and you have the most adorable Cliff
you've seen it all
right I'll take that from you
you're a tremendous Nordic midshield
dark green shield oh yeah there's a stud
I'm trying to catch that if I may be so
bold you have the points of an apex
predator but the eyes for kindly
Woodland creature
get in there and smash it all up thank
you
never stop never change for sure
it's not an obstacle course it's a soft
blend welcome to Trader Camp sir
[Music]
fantastic shower of physical exercise
get our head shoulders back smash it
take no prisoners you know exactly what
you're doing you have fabulous teeth
basically more of that but he is I never
get tired of that [__] yeah that's a
Jimmy Burke thing Jimmy bird used to
we'd sit on the [__] Street in New
York and he would do that to everybody
that walked by it'd go you brighten my
day you dull the sun with your eyes it
was just one thing after another and I
[__] would just sit there and watch
him I'd just be like
it's interesting what's this
um this is how impressing a lady can go
wrong
or some [__]
ah damn it that's how you die that's how
you die
ah
oh that can actually kill you
it's Jack too
he's jacked but [__] that's gotta hurt
did he die no he's fine just all right
embarrassed and speaking of football
being too soft uh
scroll over inflation
oh you broke it I did I'll do this in a
different browser
why is that when it has no sound what
happens you have to do something with
Google Chrome with me I don't know why
but let's just put in a different
browser God I saw that that guy hit his
head like that [__] you gotta jump out
right Brendan I mean don't do that don't
be fair
he call me fat bro
come on
bro I lost weighted last season
I look fat
I don't sell crutches bro
[Music]
I'd say you're not skinny
thank you
okay cool
he's a good player too at least I got
friends you need him he's a d tackle for
the Jets he's a stud so funny
Mike's call me fat
now I'm self-conscious bro I think that
is it boys we did it this was a good
podcast guys this was a good name no
Asian yeah name your Asian full of uh
full of contentious conversations about
serial killers and conspiracies and you
called me a pilot fish I called you a
[__] fat whale I won't talk about
that Sunday theater play
who Did That to You Genesee Theater guys
September 24th I'm not sold out yet
um at recogn Illinois and then we got
Melbourne Florida King Center Saturday
September 23rd let's get some tickets
going guys
um yeah I don't know I'll be in Florida
uh we call in Illinois I hear is a on
Sunday is happening
so I'll see all 12 of you I'll see all
12 of you there
ah let me see Munchen
uh oh yeah Covina that's September 8th
September 8th Covina California me and
Brian together one night two shows only
I think it's 7 and 9 30 in Covina
California that's the Laugh Factory
theater out there with me and Calum
together first time in forever uh
Spokane Washington Spokane Comedy Club
September September 21st the 23rd and
then Iowa Deke
Dubuque Iowa those just got announced
October 13th through the 14th Niagara
Falls November 4th and 5th then
Chicago's December 8th through the 9th
that's a Friday and Saturday only all
right get your tickets thick boy.com or
fatkz.com see you soon kids that's it
love you